nice to meet you how big is this
european migration crisis down
it's big and it's getting bigger we're
doing a story on the impacts of
climate change on migration many of the
people are clean conflicts
we just couldn't believe that some
weren't fleeing climate change
and so we're investigating more people
are more exposed to more extreme weather
and on top of that there is weaker
governance and there is violence
they have a right of being relocated
elsewhere
because they didn't cause climate change
we
in the in this industrialized north
caused climate change
i think what got me really interested in
this story is that people don't
understand that the 1951 geneva
convention protects
refugees and refugees are only those
people who are fleeing conflict or
persecution
what country and how long did it take
to get here from guinea if you're
fleeing the fact that you can no longer
support your family because your crops
don't grow because the rain doesn't fall
you have no protection no future here
so you're tortured by a dictator you
have certain rights
if i've been driven out of my country by
this a woman named mother nature
there's absolutely nothing that will
protect you
we need to either give hope to people
where they are today in their situation
of
extreme vulnerability or
we will take not just one million people
coming
this year to europe it will be millions
and millions
is it our missions that are
impoverishing your country
those who did nothing to cause climate
change they feel it
today i think this is among the most
important journalism
projects i've ever been part of and the
commitment to truth and excellence
in telling this climate change story is
simply unparalleled we have to be
much much better in investing in a
better
coming future that is the way to avoid
that we
all will live very dangerously it's 110
degrees fahrenheit
is this weather normal for this time of
year
you